[Music]
hey everybody its charlie everybody's
been freaking out about the new teaser
we got for Avengers 4 there was actually
a bunch of separate things that drop so
I try to include as many things in this
video as possible we got a better look
at Iron Man's new armor we got a look at
Thor's new armor and the rest of the
Avengers they're all wearing matching
outfits and we got an official
description of the movie our first
official description because it's in
print there's been a lot of rumors but
it's not really official until you
actually see it written on marketing
materials for the movie there's a brand
new round of that spider-man ps4 game
giveaway all you have to do to enter is
be a subscriber and leave a comment
about Marvel on the video first big
thing the official description of the
movie comes hand-in-hand with the brand
new Thor armor so I'll talk about that
first then I'll talk about Iron Man
stuff because his armor is a little bit
different we got a teaser for it earlier
but now we have a much much better look
so you look at this this is actually
official manufacturing for the movie
they're gonna be making this there were
people who saw a featurette that Disney
showed up a while ago that claimed that
the Avengers were wearing these uniforms
or this armor in the teasers so whereas
a lot of times you don't see a lot of
this toy stuff make it into the movie
it sounds like we'll actually be seeing
a version of this and it'll be something
like their quantum realm suits because
Thor doesn't need a suit he's one of the
most powerful people in the universe he
survived in the blackness of space after
being blown up by Thanos for who knows
how long before the guardians came along
looks like we're not getting paid so the
official description just reads the
Asgardian Thor wields the mighty storm
breaker in his battle against his foes
rocket teams up with a new crew to guard
the galaxy against an even greater
threat so a couple big things going on
in that the new crew that rocket joins
is the Avengers like you just have
nebula and rocket left over of course
they're gonna be hanging out with the
Avengers on planet earth in the
intervening time between the movies the
other really big thing is is what is
that even greater threat because it
doesn't represent us and I think that
they're trying to avoid any big spoilers
for who the new villain of the movie is
but it seems to confirm that while
Thanos will return like we saw at the
end of infinity war he will not be
the main villain of Avengers 4 it will
be someone else
this doesn't confirm anything about the
title there been all those Mark Ruffalo
rumors about people decoding his
audio-in thinking it's the last Avenger
a bunch of other people think that it's
going to be Avengers annihilation just
because of the plot of the annihilation
comic book about people invading from
between universes in it being way worse
than that owes none of those titles have
been confirmed it's probably gonna be a
little while before Marvel says but most
of these toys making it out these are
official Marvel quote-unquote leaks like
they leak stuff to the press is a form
of marketing to get people hyped up
before they do their real marketing
where they start actually posting this
stuff on their social media accounts
that's how you know it's officials if
Marvel posted on their main Twitter
account the suits themselves like the
white with the Avengers logo resemble a
little bit of those chest plates from
the iron Legion during age of Ultron so
maybe it's a bit of a callback to that
but then kind of doing the Jonathan
Hickman Avengers thing where they're all
wearing a version of space suits only
they're not just used for going into
outer space they're used for going into
the quantum realm or traveling between
universes just as a way to protect them
the other reason why I'm thinking of
that iron Legion scene is because that
was the last big Avengers film when they
were all together under the same roof
and Avengers 4 is them doing that again
after Civil War finally coming back
together and being a family
[Music]
how's he doing unfortunately he's still
Barton that's terrible
he's fine he's thirsty all right look
alive Jarvis it's playtime so a lot of
that is still just speculation but the
Iron Man armor that we got is actually
from the concept artist that showed us
what it looks like underneath the red
gold armor it has an under layer
remember this is supposed to be the
quote-unquote mark 85 armor so in the
way that Iron Man 3 jumped way forward
in the numbering system like you skipped
over a whole bunch just because he was
iterating and they were very specific
and you only saw them at the end of the
movie when he was blowing them up the
intervening time between infinity war
and Avengers 4 seems like when he
iterates and eventually when we do pick
up with the more advanced version of
Tony Stark this is the armor that he's
wearing which looks similar to the
nanotech armor albeit with a probably
with a whole bunch of changes under the
hood that will help him when they're
trying to use quantum energy that's the
real reason why he would need special
technology beyond say what likes or
already has biologically like he can
withstand a giant energy blast from a
Sun so why would he need a suit unless
he were fighting an enemy that were even
more powerful than that or they were
dealing with grand or cosmic concepts
like traveling the multiverse just look
at the concept art though it just looks
so badass remember these are the under
layers beneath the gold arms we got
those blurry pictures earlier no idea
why the person who posted these
initially would want to blur these
because you can see clearly what's
underneath the blur the only real
changes that he could make to his armor
that would make them even more powerful
than what he has right now or even
cooler would just be modifying them so
that they could harness quantum energy
or going full endo sim which visually
would look almost exactly like the
deployment of the nanotech armor so I
don't think this has anything to do with
endo sim probably just slightly more
hardcore and enables him to travel into
the quantum realm you may be hearing
rumors about an actual trailer
description someone tried to post a
blow-for-blow on reddit it was deleted
there's a lot of questions about whether
it's real or it's fake but if you guys
want me to do a video about that that I
can do that later this week there are a
couple of other big Marvel videos that
I'm planning on doing they just
confirmed Black Panther 2 if you didn't
think that they had already done that
they were always going to make it with
Ryan Coogler
they were just waiting for him to sign
his deal because the movie did so well
he obviously needed to get paid big-time
for the sequel so they're supposed to
start shooting that late 2019 early 2020
for about a year turn around so they
could either release that February 2021
or they could push it to May where their
biggest film of the year typically goes
if they don't have an Avengers film that
gear we don't really know when they're
gonna do that fifth Avengers film
usually it's two to three years between
big Avengers team ups but the thing is
is they make so much money and Disney is
all about making that Avengers money so
we could get to a point where you do see
an Avengers movie every other year but I
would be very surprised by that so I'm
still baking on three years after
Avengers four so that would make that
2022 but we'll learn more about the
phase four schedule at comic-con next
year so don't worry too much about that
but you probably also heard about them
confirming black widows paycheck for the
black widow movie 15 million dollars not
chump change at all that's how much
Chris Evans and Chris Hemsworth got paid
for infinity war so it's it's on par
with what the other big Avengers are
earning no worries though all this
information that's been dropping though
more frequently means that we're getting
closer to an actual trailer but I'm not
really expecting footage till like late
November early December let me know
though what do you think about this new
avengers armor what do you think they
need it for and what do you think about
the idea of an even greater threat
that's teased in this marketing language
the giveaway will stay open as I post
more Marvel videos I think I'm allowed
to post my daredevil season 3
non-spoilery review tomorrow I have to
double check on that but I'll post video
updates in the comments below
whole bunch of stuff coming up click
here to learn all about that Avengers 4
annihilation title and click here for my
new ant-man Avengers 4 video thank you
so much for watching everybody stay
awesome I'll see you guys tonight
[Music]
you